the next era of Taylor Swift is here and
she won't give a [ __ ]
that's right old Taylor Swift can't come
to the phone right now and the new one
is not shaking it up Swifties it's time
for a pulse check y'all still breathin
it's been less than 24 hours since she
dropped her new single look what you
made me do and she is out for blood
let's decode her revenge track first
line Taylor takes aim at enemy number
one Kanye and Kim don't like your little
games don't like you're tilted stage hmm
tilted stage that sound familiar
BAM it's the set up Kanye Youth on his
seat Pablo tour and remember that phone
conversation Kanye secretly recorded and
then Kim released on snapchat
yeah Taylor's not gonna let that happen
again
[Music]
she's dead
not gonna lie that one scared me all
right lover hates a single I personally
think it lacks spectacle and it didn't
reach the same fever pitch as the hype
did but there's no denying it is a
dramatic shift for the pop star I'm here
for that evolution and you know I
mentioned this yesterday long gone are
the soapy songs of romance and
heartbreak it's all about karma and
revenge
speaking of don't think Katy Perry gets
off unscathed
you'll recall Katy tweeted that Mean
Girls reference that Taylor watch out
for the Regina George and sheep's
clothing
well many fans were quick to point out
that Taylor's track has the same exact
beat as this peaches song in the movie
listen for yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
coincidence I think not and if you think
the chorus sounds an awful like right
set frets I'm too sexy for my shirt
you'd be right in fact the band is
credited as Co riders on Taylor song she
and Jack Antonoff who co-wrote look what
you made me do send them flowers and as
predicted Taylor will drop the music
video for her new single Sunday at the
VMAs we will be watching but for those
of you who won't be there this weekend
I'm bringing a piece of the show to you
right now we are giving away the
official VMA gift back all you got to do
is head over to ET online.com slash
giveaways and enter for a chance to win
you must be 18 and over and you have
until midnight Pacific time on Monday to
enter so good luck to you alright but we
do need to move on to some surprising or
not so surprising bachelor news Nick
vile and fiance Vanessa Grimaldi have
called off their engagement
yep that's right et can't confirm Nick
and Vanessa are dunzo just five months
after viewers watched their fairy tale
proposal play out on TV the pair shared
a joint statement to ET saying we gave
this relationship our all
now that's what they say but a source
tells us things were always doomed for
Nick and Vanessa quote Vanessa's not
really into the whole same thing she's
had some fun with it but that's not what
she's a bell ultimately they want
different things our source adds that a
big sticking point was where to live
Nick wanted to be in LA while Vanessa
wanted to stick close to her family in
Canada now one thing's for sure the
other cast members from Nick season I
don't think they thought it would last
look at jasmine good spilling the tea on
their relationship do you think that
Nick and Vanessa will last um you know
time will tell because I think Vanessa I
think there's so much alike to like
they're very stubborn and like you know
Vanessa's very emotional person and I
just don't know just time will tell
we'll see what do you think Vanessa
wants to do career-wise you know I don't
know I don't know if she went back to
teaching or not I think she's doing like
a charity thing
oh yeah he moved here like I know you I
think they're living together but she's
still in Canada alive so it seems like
some time spent apart she's really big
our family so we'll see if she leaves
well she didn't leave all right as if
this weekend wasn't big enough with
Sunday's Video Music Awards it's also
the series finale of Game of Thrones I
know I know I know you are distraught
you are not alone trust and with that we
have a preview of the finale episode
thanks to our resident TV expert Leah
and a delay away can you believe it I
can't believe it inter has finally
arrived and I want to know from you what
are three things fans can expect from
Sunday's finale all right here is what
we can expect for the first time ever
almost every character is in the same
place at the same time they're all in
King's Landing we're gonna be seeing a
showdown between Cersei and Jon Snow
they have never met before and just
because Dany has not been seen in any of
the promos or any of the pictures on HBO
trust me homegirls gonna be making an
appearance and I think she's gonna be
bringing her dragons with her I'm gonna
have to take your word for it I've
always seen the pilot folks I'm sorry
Danny I'm gonna make you watch the
entire show by the time the final season
airs you're gonna be an expert no it's
on my bucket list I know you guys are
obsessed with it and there's be plenty
to talk about after the finale so be
sure to join me and for a full recap on
Westeros weekly this week it's gonna be
live so tune into Ikki Facebook page
Monday 8:00 a.m. specific time it's
gonna be a lot of fun oh well much to
discuss enjoy your weekend until then
I'm gonna fly away like a dragon haha
are you guys now Taylor Swift isn't the
only one who dropped new music today in
fact there are so many fire tracks it
was so hard to choose this week's new
music Friday playlist but I think I've
done it let's kick things off with the
girls of fifth harmony whose new
self-titled album just released today
but the track I have on loop is he like
that
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah ladies you did that Congrats all
right you guys this week jared leto and
his band thirty Seconds to Mars released
walk on water their first single in four
years an ET special correspondent Kelty
Knight spoke with him exclusively about
the meaning behind the song
[Music]
I certainly have poured a lot of my
feelings of passion into my music about
wanting to win but walk on water is a
song about change yep it's a song about
freedom it's a it's an optimistic song
it's a hopeful song I think it's a song
that speaks of the times that we're
living in it
it is a chance to rally everyone
together to say something new to kind of
put a flag in the ground and to
celebrate solid right and finally Mariah
Carey laid down some vocals for this
remix of French Montana's unforgettable
and it is a banger
[Music]
me
[Music]
Mariah shouting all kinds of velvety on
that one are you guys drop those down go
enjoy your weekend but don't forget to
stick with ET online for all of your VMA
coverage this weekend we'll be back on
Monday and log knows there will be
plenty to talk about so I will see you
guys there I don't like Riya